I just want to start with I've been a
fan of yours for a long time and uh I
appreciate you doing Press today
oh thank you thanks so much
um so I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning um if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
oh
I'd like them to watch
the riches because that is my favorite
character that I've ever played and it's
probably as far away from who I am as a
person you know a um
a a a a meth addicted Traveler
um slash murderer I I would like I would
like people to know that that's not who
I am and then be pleasantly surprised
when they meet me so uh talk a little
bit about with The Witcher you play a
key role in this I don't know how much
you've been telling people about it
um uh what what have you been telling
friends and family about your
participation in this uh Witcher prequel
well I mean not much up until quite
recently because it has all been quite
Under Wraps but you know
um I've definitely told them that I was
playing a shape-shifting elf which got
some happy raised eyebrows from my son
and you know all his Kabbalah friends
are very excited I mean just to say that
I'm going into the Witcher Universe has
made every single person I've told very
very happy
um which just shows you know how
far-reaching and much Beloved the show
is when you got on the set of The
Witcher was there anything that
surprised you in terms of or anything
about the production that you know is
unusual to this or um I'm just curious
what it was like you know the behind the
scenes I know I wish I could tell you
that there was something different but
I've got the the truth is a film set is
a film's hat a film set is a film set it
is full of cables and really
hard-working people and there is this
magic when the camera rolls and
everything is sort of suspended and it's
really beautiful how everyone is there
in service of the storytelling
um so it's always magical to me no
matter what set I'm on but it was so
great that this was about a magical
story to tell us so there was something
meta about how much I enjoyed shooting
this on that note I already have to stop
I'm just gonna say like I said I've been
a fan a long time I have a fantastic day
and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thank you so much thank you